una vulneración del estado de derecho
así condenó la organización de estados
américanos la destitución de los
magistrados del tribunal supremo en el
salvador los jueces críticos del
presidente nayib buque le fueron
removidos de sus cargos junto al fiscal
general por el parlamento electo para la
legislatura 2021 2024 en la democracia
las mayorías tienen la responsabilidad
de ser garantes fundamentales para
asegurar el respeto a los derechos
humanos y las libertades fundamentales
el acceso al poder y su ejercicio con
sujeción al estado de derecho
el régimen plural de partidos y
organizaciones políticas y la separación
e independencia de los poderes públicos
también en una conversación telefónica
mantenida con bukele el secretario de
estado de eeuu rechazó la medida el
secretario de estado- anthony blinken
expresó la grave preocupación del
gobierno de eeuu por el voto de la
asamblea legislativa para destituir a
los cinco magistrados de la cámara
constitucional del salvador y señaló que
un poder judicial independiente es
esencial para la gobernabilidad
democrática expresó la misma
preocupación por la destitución del
fiscal general raúl melara quien lucha
contra la corrupción y la impunidad
y es un socio eficaz de los esfuerzos
para combatir el crimen tanto en eeuu
como en el salvador en la misma línea se
expresó el director para las américas de
la organización human rights watch quien
alertó que el país va camino a
convertirse en una dictadura la asamblea
del salvador ha juramentado nuevos
magistrados en la sala constitucional a
pesar de una sentencia que declara
inconstitucional la remoción expedita de
los magistrados de la sala se trata de
una evidente alteración del orden
constitucional y la comisión
interamericana de derechos humanos instó
al estado salvadoreño a revertir la
medida en sus redes sociales
bukele aseguró que estaban limpiando la
casa